Chris Appleton files for a divorce from
Lucas Gage after 6 months of marriage I
said well Chris can be a woman's name
but in this case I believe Chris is not
a woman's name Chris is a man's name so
you're saying the a man has filed for
divorce from another man after six
months of
marriage and then here's the
kicker uh Kim Kardashian one of
Appleton's clients officiated the
ceremony and Shenia Twain
performed
so none of that happened none of like
something happened that involved these
people but none of the things that this
news article says happened actually
happened Chris Appleton did not file for
divorce from Lucas Gage because two men
cannot divorce one another because two
men cannot marry one another because
marriage intrinsically involves sexual
difference and the complimentarity of
the Sexes and Kim Kardashian did not
officiate that wedding one because it
was not a wedding and two because Kim
Kardashian is not a priest because women
can't be priests and because Kim
Kardashian even if she were pretending
to be a priest in this case wasn't even
pretending to have some religious role
and marriage has always been both a
religious and
civil
institution but other than that the
story makes perfect sense right I say
none of this with any antipathy
whatsoever toward Chris Appleton or
Lucas Gage neither of whom I've ever
heard of I say this actually with no
antipathy toward Kim Kardashian even and
I say this certainly with no antipathy
toward guys who are a little bit light
in the loafers you know I'm from New
York I lived in La I went to the gayest
university in the United States a
disproportionate number of my friends
have unusual and Ecentric sexual desires
and behaviors I don't I love them very
dearly I have no antipathy or hatred for
anybody but this just isn't real none of
this is real it's all
fake the reason I mentioned the story is
one because we're talking about the fake
news but two because it shows you how
far how far we have to go to restore
even the basic elements of a stable
flourishing Society it is not possible
to have a stable flourishing Society if
your fundamental political
institution is wacky is ambiguous is
controversial for all of human history
everywhere on planet Earth the
fundamental political unit is the family
and the the fundamental component of the
family is a marriage and the the
fundamental aspect of the marriage is
the complimentarity of the Sexes this is
the fundamental distinction in man
kind and if we deny that things are not
going to work out very
well you might say well I I don't want
men and women to be different well okay
sorry I'm sorry that you feel that way
but they are
well I don't I don't
want marriage to be a fundamental unit
of society okay well man's a coupling
creature and the political animal and
that's just the way it is I'm sorry you
feel that way maybe you'd prefer a
thruple or a quadruple maybe you'd
rather we all live in some deracinated
desexed utopian Vision that you might
have where where those things don't
matter but that's not that's not the way
it is to quote the great baseball player
Oscar gamble some people don't think
it'd be like it is but it do but it
do and so I I know that there are a lot
of conservatives who think well if if
only we just there are even some
sensible liberals especially sensible
liberals who will say we just got to cut
this woke stuff we just gota come on man
[Music]
you're we we are so far removed from a
normal stable flourishing Society
that what what would be required to get
back to any semblance of of good living
is going to require far greater
confidence and far greater Clarity
because Clarity is Charity baby that's
what I think right now go to balanceof
nature.com use promo code nolles kwes
living a healthy lifestyle it's not easy
especially when you're always on the go
you need simple manageable routines to
make sure you're getting the proper
nutrition every day which is why I'm a
huge fan of balance of nature balance of
nature fruits and veggies are a great
way to make sure you're getting
essential nutritional ingredients every
single day balance of nature uses an
advanced cold vacuum process that
encapsulates fruits and vegetables into
Whole Food supplements without
sacrificing their natural antioxidants
the capsules are completely void of
additives fillers extracts synthetics
pesticides or added sugar the only thing
in balance of nature is fruit and veggie
capsules are well fruits and veggies
there's never been an easier way to make
sure you're getting your daily dose of
fruits and vegetables go to balance of
nature.com use promo code n canw for 35%
off your first order as a preferred
customer that's balanceofnature.com
promo code NES kwes for 35% off your
first preferred order balanceof
nature.com there's some new feminist
Marvel movie out based on Captain Marvel
which I labored through for the daily
wire some years ago whenever it came out
it's with some woman Brie Larson is the
actress in it it was really just
Dreadful and then they made a sequel to
it called the Marvels which just came
out and it appears to be the lowest
opening weekend in Marvel franchise
history it pulled in 47 million bucks so
this is good for the culture because I
don't I don't like the Marvel movies
generally I really don't like feminist
movies uh un unless they're at least uh
provocative or interesting or show me
something from a new angle and it's not
just Joe Scarboro tier you know my
enemies are fascists kind of stuff but
but that rarely happens in in any movie
especially feminist movies so I don't
like that and then you combine the the
two so you've got this really shallow
formulaic movie that just inserts a
bunch of woke girl boss uh catchphrases
into it and it's just absolutely
unbearable so it's good that the people
rejected that but it's really bad
because it means I'm going to have to
watch this movie now because the sadist
in the control room Mr Davies is going
to make me do it so that I can give a
review if if this movie is a a news
story if people either because it's so
popular because it's so unpopular I
guess I'm GNA have to watch this
thing even though I know I know how bad
it's going to be because I saw the first
one when this movie was announced it was
lauded for having three female leads
that your first sign it's just that
South Park clip Kathleen Kennedy make it
more lame and four female leads and no
one wants to see that because what
people want to see when they go see a
hero movie whether it's an old western
with John Wayne or whether it's a new
movie with Chris Pratt they want to see
a man do manly things Feats of Strength
because men are physically stronger than
women and men are more publicly oriented
than women women tend to be more
nurturing and oriented toward the
private life and so the men want to go
see a man go out there and conquer the
world and they want to see a woman be
saved because men want to save a damsel
in distress because Men actually love
don't hate women they love women and
what do the women want to see they want
to see the same thing that's the big
secret no women are looking up to bre no
little girls are looking up to Brie
Larsson or any of these ridiculous women
these feminist women characters because
those feminist women characters are
divorced from reality and everything
about them is divorced from reality
their physical abilities most obviously
women can't beat men in fights pretty
much ever under any circumstances it
just can't happen we covered that story
yesterday 15-year-old High School boys
soccer beats professional women's soccer
like every time so that is the most
obvious but furthermore the notion that
women don't desire men that's just false
that's not true a woman needs a man like
a fish needs a bicycle like the
feminists say it's just not true none of
this stuff is true and so it doesn't
resonate for the men it doesn't resonate
for the women doesn't resonate for
anybody according to the Box Office
return and I bet it's not going to
resonate for me when freaking Ben Davies
makes me watch it man what a great clip
that was it was good huh now Mak sure
hey you got to ring that Bell subscribe
to the Michael nolles podcast we'll see
you next time